Sao nay ngày 12 ngày 9 ngày 9 ngày 9 ngày 9 ngày 9, không ăn phường tránh hơn, thành phố xin mình, cho biết đơn vị vừa bóc gỡ đường dây mà truy lớn,
mắt và sư li của mình tả nội tượng.
Trước đó, qua công tác nắm tình hiện địa bàn, phát hiện nghi vấn về và đặc tổ chức sự giụng mà truy tại khách sản à cà.
Quà sách mình, sát định trên nhật quan, sinh năm 1970, có giấu hiệu 1 ban trải phép chức mà truyết.
Đại li của quan lần nguyễn bảo ơn, sinh năm 1970, phương tức nối mật của các đối tượng là lội dụng nơi lưu chụ khi nào,
nên là qua các môi quan hiện các nhân, trên vị dụng của sự giụng mà truy tự chế,
tổ chức sự giụng theo nhỏ nhỏ nhỏ nhằm chánh sự chú ý của lực lượng chức nắm.
Đến quý thành sau năm 1970, không ăn phương tránh hơn và lượng phối hộ của phòng cạnh rất đều tra tội phạm về mặt dưới tổ chức phát,
bắt sự và sử li của mình tả nối tượng.
Lực lượng công an tu dữ mà tuy các loại vụ mê tham phê tà mình, kê tà mình, mở đe mở a cùng nhiều giụng của sự giụng mà truy, cùng nhiều tăng bật liên quan khác,
kích quả sẽ nhẹm cho thấy nhiều đối tượng dương tình với mặt tuy.
Đăng chú ý, chào số các đối tượng bị bắt sự col·le dưới lình,
hẹn dành tăng nhật tự, liên nghiệp cà sĩ, nhạc sĩ.
Các quan trưng năng sau lịch lây dưới lình và trình khánh xuya có số hiệu tổ chức sự giụng chế phép chức mặt tuy.
Giang lây dưới lình còn bị xác liện có hình vì tạng trữ chế phép chức mặt tuy.
Hình công an phương tránh hơn đã truyền vụ xưa đến cơ quan cạnh sau đều tra công an thành phố chiming
và tổ bà mi chiến đối tượng về các hình vì một bán, tổ chức sử dụng và tăng trữ chai phép chức mặt tuy.
Sự lây hình chính và đối tượng đi càng hiện bắt bột chiến đối tượng.